[Music]
good evening I'm Alexandra rose and the
executive director at the long now
foundation as probably many of you heard
today there was a sort of a landing but
over and it's almost 15 years ago the
head of the Rosetta mission space
program I believe was doing a vanity
search and if you remember what 1999 was
like in the web there was like there was
that one page that had all of it on it
and so they he came up with the auras at
a project which predated his in terms of
web presence and then he emailed us out
of the blue and said oh well you have
this really awesome
disc with all the languages on it and we
have this spacecraft called Rosetta
would you like to put one of these discs
on the spacecraft
and here's 1999 we had no idea like
would the mission even to get off the
ground or anything like that but we did
make an early prototype disc and Jim
Mason the director at the time flew to
French Guiana and had it installed on
the spacecraft and then it didn't launch
because they missed their window and
then it launched three years later and
then spent the last ten years traveling
to comet 67p and just today after being
that being orbiting that comet for a few
months they sent down the lander and
these are the the shots that we have of
the lander as it descended from the
spacecraft and that was the approach the
last approach shot that was publicly
released anyway they they lost signal
after it went down for a little bit then
got signal back says and it sounds like
it bounced a little bit didn't harpoon
the surface as expected but is on the
surface and they're waiting for the
comet to come back
to evaluate where it's at but that's the
status of the Rosetta project I think
with the the level of success that we've
had with the Mars landing and and even
with this one even if it's not a total
success the level of difficulty of
slingshotting around multiple planets
and coming up to the same speed and
trajectory of a comet and then landing
on it with almost no gravity is is
probably generally underappreciated the
and I think it fits well into the topic
tonight of the Technium that that that
we're now doing things that that are
just totally impossible and that they
take networks upon networks upon
networks of people to achieve and of
machine systems that we don't fully
understand but tonight's long short is
is a great homage to that difficulty as
well as the Rosetta project itself thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in us walk with me
perhaps we should find you something a
little less challenging I don't
understand I planned everything let me
do it again
once upon a time really this is a good
one
I promise what is the key to life on
earth water
water
a long time the origins of
and indeed life on our home planet in an
absolute mystery we began searching for
answers beyond Earth where could all
this water have come from in time we
turned to comets one trillion celestial
balls of ice dust complex molecules left
over from the birth of our solar system
once thought of as messengers of doom
and destruction and yet so enchanting we
were to catch one staggeringly ambitious
plan are you talking about the Rosetta
mission
throw me the probe
[Music]
we harnessed whole planets on their
gravity to chase down the comet
so many things could have gone wrong if
failure at launch an error in the
calculations collisions throw many
unknowns with the technology we had back
then we may as well have been shooting
from a slingshot
and tell me what was it all for
knowledge yes but we also wanted to show
what was possible
[Music]
I know all this from the archives there
were bigger missions after yes it was
the first one to catch a comet ambition
stubbornness nothing has changed
before we pick ourselves up again and we
adapt I was watching you earlier who
actually did everything right I
destroyed your rock
I needed to see how you would react
already reset
nicely done
let's begin
[Music]
[Music]
boom boom kind of reminds me of
interstellar which is another ambitious
movie and a good one evening I'm Stuart
Brandt from the long now foundation when
Drew endy was on the stage couple months
ago he was describing when the people
who were founding the discipline of
synthetic biology were asking themselves
how do we actually do this how do we
make a new discipline grow and be
responsible and be fun and engage people
and the master honor they talked to Lynn
Conway who was one of the great
designers of computer chips and she said
oh go meta but which she meant you know
go up a level which worked out very well
for them and it led them to doing the I
Jim Jamboree so bringing all the kids in
the world to compete building the
organisms and racing they're racing them
conceptually and in real life and
synthetic biology is often running and
is continuing to deserve itself from
increasingly meta angle well Kevin
Kelley is a founder founding editor of
Wired magazine has been looking at
digital technology and culture for quite
a while and nobody does a better job of
going meta than Kevin is an important
book he wrote a couple years ago is
called what technology wants and I think
that one fair answer to that this
technology was Kevin to Kelly Hu tried
to figure it out and explain what's
going on
thank you Kevin yeah that is indeed I
think today humanity's a little bit
bigger than it was yesterday with the
landing of the of the probe that's sort
of what detecting him is about what I
wanted to do this evening was to take an
idea that has been around for a long
time that's sort of been in the realm of
poetry and to try to treat it seriously
that idea is the idea of a planetary
technological super organism
it's a terrible set of words but we
don't have very many good words for that
and what I'm going to try and do is to
add some words to it it's an idea that
has many different names and has been
around for a long time and what I'm
trying to do is to apply it is to move
it into the realm of science to try to
talk about it definitely and to and to
and to actually take the idea seriously
so superorganism is a we think we know
what that means
it means something like a beehive of bee
colony and Wilson wrote a book about the
super organism of ants and bees these
are interesting because they cannot
regulate the temperature in their own
bodies but they can regulate the
temperature of a hive they live for only
six weeks therefore their memory only
lasts for six weeks but the memory of a
beehive can be four years we know about
swarms which are like a murmuring of
starlings they can act almost as a
single shape as it moves through the air
how they do that with no leader it's an
emergent phenomena we know about
termites another social insect that can
create this architecture that is again
thermo regulating it actually has air
conditioning
worked and of course the scale this
thing is way beyond even what a termite
can perceive and yet they can build
these things with great accuracy
that's a superorganism and a reef which
is an interesting super an organism
because this many species not just a
single species and the reef itself is
being protected by and and cultivated by
the individual separate species who are
course interested in their own survival
but are actually doing things to
maintain this very large structure and
that's another example of a super
organism I wanted a more technical
definition of super organism and even ed
Wilson's book on the super organism
doesn't give us one so I went to
Wikipedia and I found that was a pretty
good definition a collection of agents
acting in concert to produce phenomena
governed by the collective knowing
trouble is I wrote that that they were
quoting me which really dampened my
confidence in the Wikipedia it's like
it's supposed to be smarter than me so
the we don't really have a I mean we
have an idea of about stupid organisms
so I'm using this word and I'm admitting
the fact that it's actually kind of
fuzzy it's actually kind of vague we I
wrote a book out of control which was
sort of trying to look at the phenomena
of emergent behavior that comes from
collections of agents and that's where
this quote comes from but there is
something about these organizations they
exhibit some of these four behaviors
which is that they tend to regulate
something to keep to kind of bring
things back and into some kind of range
so there's there's a sense in which
they're self-governing they also exhibit
power loss scaling which I'll mention a
bit later which is this idea that there
is
there's an association between the
different scales so there's there's a
sense of things operating at multiple
multiple levels there's also a
persistent disequilibrium which is the
fancy word to say that the super
organism is never at rest it's always
slightly out of kilter and it's always
catching itself so there's a dynamicism
about it that it isn't static and lastly
of course there's emergent behaviors
which mean that there are things that it
does that cannot be found in any of the
parts so famously I mean you could look
at the behavior of a single be forever
and never really see the behavior of a
hive in it that's some of the qualities
of a super organism and I would apply
that now to technology and this is a
slide inspired by Matt Ridley who was a
speaker here on the seminar at before
and if you take these two objects who
are roughly the same size the one on the
left you could probably make in a good
weekend with some instruction the one on
the right you not only could not make
but even everybody here as smart as we
all are could not make together because
it requires a network of other
technologies to support it so that
technology of a mouse is made up of
hundreds of technologies and they
themselves are all requiring hundreds of
other technologies to support it and so
the entire thing becomes saturated with
different dependencies of technology
supporting other technologies and I'm
really a fan of this art project done by
a guy named Thomas Thwaites I think how
you pronounce it it's called the toaster
project and he decided to try and make a
toaster from scratch from scratch
meaning like from the ore from the oil
and that's the suitcase of copper ore
and it turns out that this is really
difficult to do smelting copper is
incredibly toxic it was just even
getting the war was was like a whole
year in getting permission to move it
whatever it is and so he got this ore
and he did smelt it in his backyard
using kind of some other technologies
but keeping it keeping it to a minimum
and he was actually able to cast this
framework this was the basic mechanism
which was a big deal believe me this is
a huge project and then he actually got
some crude oil which he did not get
himself but he purchased which was okay
it's a little bit and he started casting
the plastic case of it and he was
carving this wood blocks and he was
pouring it in and there's an exam and he
had made other parts eventually this is
the toaster that he made from scratch
it's it's in England so as a three prong
plug it's 220 volts and it worked for 30
seconds
okay but just to kind just to kind of
show you us I think the great for me the
great reveal he did was he put it in a
Best Buy Lang store at the real cost so
these other toasters are about $30 and
his was $2,000 and the point of this was
I don't know what the point of is but
what I take the point of it is to show
you the depth of the support the subsidy
that we have with technology so when you
hear maker people talk about they're
gonna make something it's they're gonna
make a little bit of it something
they're gonna add to last a little bit
they're gonna buy screws or they're
gonna buy some copper or they're gonna
buy plastic which has a hole deep
network of technologies that have
supported that of course the point of
these technologies is they form networks
in the sense that they're all
self-supporting to make a saw you need
to have a hammer to hammer the saw blade
and to have a hammer you need the saw to
cut the wood so these things are
self-supporting and the more complex of
technology the more self-supporting and
self dependent it is you might think of
these things as it's any invention any
complex invention as a network of
dependent and self-sustaining different
technologies so we have networks of
these nothing is really a standalone
except for maybe that stone hammer
anything complex in today's tech world
is a network of things and that's also
true for ideas ideas are not standalone
ideas ideas are a network of other ideas
that support them and we are required to
make them happen and so usually a new
idea is just the last little bit that's
added to a network that already exists
and that's why simultaneous independent
inventions is the norm they happen again
again because any idea new idea is going
to be resting on a whole network of
other inventions so
we take that idea of the toaster as
being dependent on lots of other
technologies we keep looking further and
further back we come to this huge web of
all the technologies together from
concrete to plumbing to the electrical
wires running through this place all
these things together in the furthest
abstraction and that's what I call the
Technium that that's not the technology
is singular that collective that super
organism so to speak of all these things
is what I call the Technium to give to
give it a words and we know we so we can
use and talk about it so the Technium is
that is that is that web of all these
things together there are requiring each
other to continue and just as there are
many parts in any very complex thing and
the parts themselves are smaller than
the whole so this is a diagram of a cell
so the cell has thousands and thousands
of parts and thousands and thousands of
metabolic pathways which this is a
diagram of and none of those parts are
living and yet the cell itself has life
okay so so there is a weighing what's
even the most complex systems we know
are made up of parts that don't exhibit
any of the evidence or any of the
behaviors of the whole and so a which is
not alive in any sense of the word any
more than then a metabolic compound in a
cell is but I'm suggesting that the
entire super organism of all the
technology of a technique itself can in
some ways exhibit lifelike behaviors and
that technological super organism is
this thing that we are in the middle of
we're surrounded by it right now our
lives depend on it
most of our jobs are involved in it it's
most of what we care about these days
to some extent and that is what we're in
and I'm trying to take it seriously this
idea and I'm calling it the Technium
that's that this is my shorthand for it
but what I'm not talking about is Gaia
so Gaia is another idea very much like
this started by James Lovelock and
Lamarque lists which suggests that the
natural habitat of the planet also is a
super organism it also exhibits its own
kind of emergent behavior it acts as if
it was its own organism in the sense it
is self-regulating and and the claims of
Gaia are very strong it's not just that
it's all acting together but in the fact
that this system of life on this planet
as actually trying to bend the entire
planet to be more conducive to more life
it's actually having an effect or has
had an effect on the geological
structure of the earth that life the
four billion years of life have actually
affected the landscape the mountains the
weather continental drift all those
things actually had been affected in
some ways influenced by life on this
earth by Gaia as it forms a system so
that's the strong version of Gaia and
that's not quite what I'm talking about
right now though I'll come back to it
I'm also not talking about the world
brain which was HT to Elsa's term for
that contraption that that that large
thing that we seem to be making even
when he wrote this book almost a century
ago and what he had in mind was
something that we would now recognize
more closer to the web but it was again
he was talking mostly about just the
mechanical aspects of what we're making
and I'm not quite talking about that in
this idea
and I'm not talking about the noosphere
which is a term by Leroy and P Rashad on
the French when is the French priests
anthropologist with this idea of all of
what we might think of today is more of
like human collective consciousness or
global consciousness it's about this
seven billion humans and our collective
presence together
that that's the maybe one version of the
new sphere so I'm not talking about just
that either I'm talking about and I'm
not talking about the singularity
exactly though I will come back to this
because there isn't actually an element
of the singularity but I don't mean in
the way that that singularity University
say might think about it there's a
little bit to that and so I will turn to
that so it's something in between all
these things it's this very large
machine that's made up of humans it's
actually made of a lot of technology but
it also has an influence in a role and
it's tied to the natural world as well
so I am trying to say like let's imagine
if this was a new critter a new organism
let's treat it as if it was an organism
and I'm gonna try to describe it as if I
was a biologist if you were finding it's
in a petri dish and you were trying to
say what what can we say about it and I
think the extra little task I give
myself is imagining I'm a you know from
another planet and I'm going to go
through and I'm trying to catalog all
the civilizations in our galaxy and how
would I make a taxonomy and where would
i how would I describe what we have
could could we do it in a way as if I
was a biologist on a field trip so we
you know first question is or are there
planetary civilization classifications
and actually there there are a bunch I
collect all the ones that I knew about
there's a lot of them and the kind of
example of one is Kardashev scale which
was about the
energy of different planets and so
roughly if you could if a civilization
could control all the solar energy from
this from that Sun that came onto the
planet that was one if they could
control all the solar energy be giving
off by that star that was a to if it
could harness all the energy in the
galaxy that was three and Carl Sagan
kind of turned that into a little
formula and he estimated that the earth
today we were about 0.74 that's just a
single dimension and I collected all the
other known planetary classification
systems that I could find the most
elaborate one was some Star Trek and
they had a lot of different ones in
their imaginary world but all of them
were on single dimensions and of course
it's very obvious in a taxonomy of
civilizations of planetary civilizations
that they wouldn't have just a single
axis you'd have many many different
dimensions and so to be a matrix but
that's we haven't gotten that far so we
don't really have very good
classification schemes but in my search
for trying to describe what we have I
was asking myself what can we say about
this planetary system in a global sense
and it turns out that whenever you're
asked like what do we have globally X
take X and we try to find the global
dimensions of it there's actually
there's a very uniform answer which is
we have no idea we have we don't know
the one the one metric that we've
measured to some reliability is
population of humans and even that as we
see because we're revising these numbers
all the time we don't even know that but
how many telephones is our own on the
planet how many miles of road how many
schools how much fresh water the answer
is we don't really have any idea and I
know that a little bit because I was
involved in a project with Stuart and
Ryan to try to collage all the living
species on this planet it seems they're
very reasonable thing to do if we found
life on another planet say Mars one of
the first things you would do is send
the prose
back and try to do a systematic survey
of all the life that would be on that
planet but we haven't done it to her own
home planet we think we know about 5%
the 1.8 million species that we have
discovered we think maybe about 5% and
there are some methods that we can make
that estimate but we basically have no
idea we certainly don't know what's in
the deep oceans and these are mostly
small things I mean there's no new very
few new birds will discover but new
insects and and below smaller than that
we have no idea that unfortunately is
the answer to most of the questions we
have about the planet as a whole and the
fact that we don't know even the species
is really important because very early
on we humans about 10,000 years ago and
the vanilla earlier we basically have
eliminated say for instance all the
megafauna these are the megafauna that
used to be in Mexico that were basically
wiped out about ten thousand years ago
by human hunters that had a huge effect
on our continent and in the shape and
the ecology that's not just a biological
effect a biological consequence it
actually has even geological
consequences and while we know about
global change right now and rising co2
that actually while it's very very
drastic right now it actually began a
long time ago it began even at the
beginning of Agriculture this slide is
actually supposed to be your BC so even
in pre-industrial ages we were beginning
to our our inventions our technologies
were beginning to affect the planet in a
geological way so we know about 5000
natural minerals and most of those
minerals there maybe about 100 are very
very common but the rest of them are
actually very rare
we've made manufactured a thousand
artificial minerals and some of them in
very large quantities like concrete
which actually is in more abundance than
many of some of the rare other natural
minerals and so in that sense we're
actually again having geological
consequences with our inventions
it's a geological force it's not just
biological so returning back to this
machine that we're making with the
extended the extension of our of our
minds into matter what can we say about
it one thing is is that the most rapidly
expanding quantity or item on this
planet is nothing biological it's
nothing concrete it's actually
information information is expanding at
sixty six and a half percent a year
almost anything else we make over the
span of decades is only increasing at
seven percent there's no biological
phenomena that we say where things are
increasing at that rate and that
information is in the realm right now of
a million Zetas if we keep going
there'll be a million Zetas in 2050 I'll
tell you about it said is in a minute so
the storage if we counted up all the
storage in the entire planet right now
and we mapped it out that's the graph of
what it would look like and and that is
the graph of an explosion basically
right if you take the surface area per
second that we are manufacturing it it's
an explosion in fact we were laying
cable at the speed of sound for a while
okay I mean that we were laying 340
meters of cable fiber-optic in the
planet per second for a while that's how
fast it was and this digital world
that's exploding if again if you
calculate the volume of stuff that we're
making per second it actually is just
like a nuclear
that's that's the that's the the power
that that's the velocity that we're
creating it but unlike a nuclear
explosion which is over in seconds
fractions of a second this is continuing
year after year after year so that's
that that's the scale which we're
affecting this increase in the world and
again if you just look at the number of
transistors that we're making it's
phenomenal and we're making this one
into one very large machine because it's
all being connected so you could think
about all the transistors in the world
that are now all being connected
together in the same way that the
transistors in your computer or your
phone are all connected together we're
connecting all the devices together and
so I did a calculation of the number the
total number of transistors and all the
devices that are connected and it's some
you know crazy number these numbers are
changing they don't really mean anything
what's a quintillion anyway right
there's a lot of them right there's a
lot of links there's a lot of there's
the speed at which this is happening is
is you can almost hear it I mean
literally if you actually tried to
listen to it and the total amount of
memory is really huge and the number of
clicks that people are making these
little synapses they're actually at the
same scale as a human brain the number
of links and the number of clicks in the
web or a number of links in the web it's
roughly approximate to the number of
neurons and synapses in the human brain
that's and that's we consider the human
brain the most complicated complex thing
that we know about so that is that's
what the Technium is is that's a scale
right now the only thing is your brains
not doubling every 18 months okay and
that's what we're that's what we're
doing here so by 2040 this machine will
exceed in terms of this kind of the
mechanical count of its transistors and
synapses it will exceed that all the
capacity or all the the metrics of the
humans on earth and that's why people
like Ray Kurzweil will say well then
you know then we'll have a new brain but
there's a whole hierarchy of the way
things work in terms of autonomy so
right now you can have a manufactured
superorganism that doesn't do very much
it's just it's just a very large machine
that is just a machine that's very large
that has its own emergent behaviors it
doesn't necessarily have to be
autonomous but it could be that would be
another phase would be you have
something that shows some autonomy maybe
like an old starfish level it's not
smart but it's autonomous or a cricket
or a mushroom you could also have a
superorganism that what had some kind of
intelligence maybe like a mouse it's not
conscious but it's intelligent or you
curse you could have a super organism
that was consciously just because you
have a super organism doesn't mean that
half they have to have consciousness
that's what I'm saying and I think that
actually what we've made so far to date
is somewhere just above the manufactured
level it may have some autonomy but it
doesn't necessarily have to it's sort of
like a technological mushroom okay a
planet-sized mushroom that this is
necessarily smart but it does have maybe
some emerging autonomy so there's other
ways in which this has some lifelike
attributes one of which is that if you
take a plot of the metabolism of most
biological organisms it's ten watts per
kilogram or less one to ten and the data
server actually these days is almost at
that same rate so you can almost see
that these data forms have sort of a
biological like metabolism in fact you
can this is where the scaling laws come
in because you can plot all the animals
on a power-law so basically per weight
they have a very very strict adherence
to the law of metabolism and even plants
do too
in fact you can even scale up for lots
of organized matter this is Geoffrey Wes
work at the Santa Fe Institute so cities
again an extended type of technology
also exhibits the same power law in it
in both the good and bad both crime rate
as well as wealth both how fast people
walk as well as the cost of their houses
that that this kind of a scaling law is
very very particular to complex systems
like an organism and Jeffrey West
actually noticed a very key thing which
is that while they follow a power law
which is basically defined as one on a
log scale things that were just slightly
above one and things that were just
things that scaled just slightly below
one had a huge difference there was a
huge difference in their behavior even
though they were very close in first
approximation you says the power law
that little difference made a great
difference and that was if it was
greater than one there was unbounded
growth and if it was less than one
there'd be growth and then collapse okay
and so cities generally were super
exponential and organizations and
companies were generally below one
sublinear and the question really is is
well what's this Technium as a whole and
we don't know the answer to that city is
certainly obey this idea of unbounded
growth there are very few cities they
ever gone extinct completely they're
very slow to they do but they're very
very slow to but we don't know what the
Technium as a whole is we haven't
actually been able to do that
calculation but I want to give you what
a picture of this looks like this is
what the Technium looks like on the
planet it is not this which is from Star
Wars this is a planet they've engineered
that
now what we see we see something much
more biological than that and to give
you an example of where this may come
from is there's a kind of kind of an art
project called the degree confluence and
it would take the arbitrary grid that
we've applied to the planet with round
around numbers latitude and longitudes
and where they crossed would form kind
of a grid for random sampling and so you
actually have people whose hobby it is
is to find a latitude and longitude was
0 0 rammed it even numbers and to go
visit where they cross and take a
picture ok and and and that's the map on
of the ones that have been completed so
far and if you take China the most
densely populated country in the world
and you take some of the debris
confluences that have been photographed
you'll see that the most populated
country in the world is not very
developed it's some era culture and a
lot of wilderness or scrub and very few
buildings this is a random sampling of
what China looks like and if you take
the earth it's even more wild it's the
average place on earth is not developed
but cities are and they are forming
these kind of nodes like a neuron in
which they're connected by these
communication threads which are roads
and other communication devices and so
if you take the plot of all the cities
over a million you can kind of see they
form a very uneven kind of biological
looking pattern or even the mega cities
that are coming or the mega cities that
will be there in 2050 this is a map of
what that pattern of human civilization
looks like on this planet or will look
like in 2050 here's another of you can
see how spikey it is it's not an even
engineered coat around the planet human
density again is uneven this is mobile
coverage uneven 3G and
even here's the oceanic cables these are
the neurons connecting between the the
continents there's a thousand floating
sensors in the ocean right now there's
this whole network of ocean sensors
transportation routes airport traffic
looking like neurons flight paths air
traffic air connections Twitter social
media mapped on top of a city across the
country here's Facebook connections
social connections around the globe
electrical grid you can see it's these
are the ten excuse me of the thousand
communication satellites around the
planet in the halo these are I can ERV
system that's that's the pattern that we
have and there's a million eyes that
we've added to that nervous system a
billion eyes actually trillion eyes
they're ever they're coming okay so so
we're actually cloaking this thing with
senses now we're giving microphones and
cameras and accelerometers moisture
sensors everything we're connecting
together in this kind of by our own
biometrics were feeding into this thing
as well as the quantified self Gary wolf
and myself trying to capture everything
that we do with their own bodies and the
Internet of Things of course we're
connecting everything we make everything
we manufacture putting a little tiny bit
of chip into it and we're connecting it
and that is that's the thing that we're
making so we have this super machine and
it right now it consumes this the
Technium consumes three-quarters of the
energy that we use it's not really for
our benefit directly it's for the you
know we have we're heating our garages
for our car it's that sense in which the
Technium itself for the benefit of other
technologies most of the inner energy
that we consume is for the benefit of
the Technium
and in fact 5% electricity we use is
just running the Internet
that will continue to grow so this
Technium this thing we're making is the
longest-running machine we've ever made
most machines the time life of any
complexity that you can run it and is
maybe hours days weeks or years this has
been going on for decades this is our
longest-running machine but then another
definition of superorganisms is that
parts die when the whole dies
and so we are dependent on this machine
and if this machine did not work we
would not continue to live so we are in
a symbiotic relationship with this this
thing and I want to come back then to
describing a little bit more because I
mentioned it's obviously that we're kind
of making a world brain but but it's not
just that we're also making a new sphere
we're taking all the humans in on the
planet and we're connecting together and
we're creating some kind of collective
thought and we're also we have Gaia and
we're interfacing with Gaia and this
what we're making is affecting Gaia so
there is there is a sense in which those
three spheres are part of this and I
would say yes we have the Technium we
have humanity we have Gaia and those
three spheres of influence those three
fears spheres of activity and action are
actually three phases of the big thing
whatever that thing is okay it's so this
thing is is is is three there's three
corners to it there's technology humans
in nature Gaia and that that is forming
this planetary thing is not just a
technology it's not just us in our minds
it's not just guy it's all three
together and interesting to me taking
kind of a page from Stuart's
thinking they'd already different rates
so Gaius are operating on scale of IANS
humanity centuries and Technium zazz
months or daily or something it's just
really really fast so so these three
things one way to distinguish him it's
actually maybe talking about the rates
in which they they operate so that thing
doesn't have a name it needs a name I
tried thinking about a name so I first
draft suggestion was I thought the whole
sphere the hollow sphere unfortunately
is something in Star Star Wars there's a
little device you hold it has 3d in it
but I think this is a better use for
there for the name we can call it maybe
hollows so the hollows is all these is
it's the it's the human all the seven
billion nine billion humans thinking to
connect it together it's it's all the
stuff that we've made with our minds
connected together and it's all
interfacing with Gaia which itself is a
super organism so I'm calling that
hollows just for the time being and
there I think there are seven frontiers
in this hollows one is new math okay so
you know we had this it's big it's
really big the kind of numbers that
we're talking about even with data is
huge ten to the 30 it was like we don't
know how to operate that in real time we
don't know how to do that kind of math
we don't have algorithms that anywhere
near allow us to to manage all this
complexity it's way beyond anything that
we have and in fact we don't even have
really good terms right now we're
talking about exit and Zetas well we
don't even have words that come after
Yoda we there's no terms
that's how blank this is there's lada
and Halla
but yeah yeah so I think we could take a
mol right - I forgot it was number 10 -
20 30 we call it 10 to 23 bytes is 1
mole so then we've got mega moles and
Giga moles and pedo moles or EXO moles
and if you're not big enough then we can
take a plunk which is 10 to the 34th
bytes and we can talk about killer
plants and mega plugs I mean we are
gonna be operating in this realm very
soon and this is a huge opportunity for
anybody who's into math or computer
science because we really don't know how
to manipulate things it's a scale I call
it silly onyx right there's zillions of
stuff so we're going into Zoli onyx
there's new economics all right we have
one there's one economy there's not
national economy there's one economy
this this is the beat of you know all
the different major stock markets
behaving as if there's one market there
is only one market we have flash crashes
with things and this was a famous thing
couple years ago where where it's just
dip nobody knew why no one has
everything no one's has ever come up
with any explanation it just went down
on its own as an emergent phenomena
because there's one thing and it kept so
we have slow earthquakes we can moot
which can move through the earth without
really knowing it and I think we're
gonna have thoughts happening on the
super organism that we're not even going
to be aware of because they're hot
they're operating in such a wide long
frequency that we can hardly even feel
it well some of these ideas will be at
such a large frequency or a long
frequency that we will have trouble
detecting them there's new biology there
are so many things that could go wrong
that while we have we know about flus
and cancer and poisonings
but we'll have those equivalent on a
superorganism if you have a super new
organism it will get ill it will have
diseases it
have phobias compulsions oscillations
that's what that's how these things
operate if you have a large system you
have illnesses in those systems and so
we were going to be confronting new
kinds of illnesses what are we doing
well there is a great idea of putting an
Internet in elegy where you take some of
the the advantages of the immune system
have and you import it right into the
system so you again you take a
biological idea and you try to implement
something that we have in our own bodies
and other living bodies have which is a
very sophisticated system there's no
such thing as zero tolerance in an
immune system it's all about tolerance
at different levels but you have some
you have need some very sophisticated
tools in order to make something like
that happen this by the way is an
attempt to take an immune idea to spam
where you're actually not looking at the
continent span you're actually looking
at the behavior of malware as it goes
through the system the flows of it so
they can even there on the left to us
the ordinary flow and on the right was a
malware a flow and you could actually
without again looking at the content
just looking at how it behaves be able
to discern it in a kind of amia logical
way we need new minds I don't like to
think about AI I think about utilitarian
telogen so artificial smartness this is
kind of this idea of a web-based service
we get it over the cloud and because
it's based in the cloud the more people
use it the smarter it gets the smarter
gets more people use it recently we saw
this fabulous demonstration where they
took the stills from about a million
different YouTube clicks clips and they
took it to the AI Google and they said
what do you see
and it painted this picture which is a
cat
it didn't say cat it just said I see
this and it said I basically it's saying
I see this I see cats
on the Internet no one asked it no one
said anything about cats but I see cats
so AI is very powerful and here's where
I want to talk about the singularity III
I think there's two kinds of
similarities strong and weak and the
strong kind is the kind of the Ray
Kurzweil where we're gonna make this
super machine and it's gonna make
another super machine faster and the
idea is if you look at these exponential
curves they're saying look they're good
in the near future they're going up but
the problem with an exponential curve is
that they they're always going to go up
anywhere along the entire path they're
gonna go up and they'll still be going
up so it's always near and it has always
been near for the past hundred years so
there's no exponential curve should not
really inform this idea of a singularity
at all but Ray's idea is is that there's
two step one is you make a smarter than
us AI and then step two you have
immortality it's like there's a lot in
between there there's a lot in between
era and his ideas if you have something
really smart that will solve all the
problems of health and mortality but
that's not the way things work is
because biological phenomena take time
you have to do experiments you could
take all the super intelligence in the
world they can read all the literature
and medical literature there is right
now and you're not gonna be able to
figure out how to cure cancer just by
thinking about it
I call that think ISM a lot of these
guys are really smart they think the
answer to everything is thinking about
it but you need data you need you need
to do experiments and so that idea of a
single arity happening just because we
make something smarter than us I don't
think it's going to work but I do think
there's one aspect to the similarity
which is true which is that it means
that we we can make something in a
larger scale that we can't really see
what's going to happen we can't really
imagine what something would happen
would be like at another level in the
word
and I think that sense of singularity is
going to be true if we have Auto
enhancing AI I think that's a
possibility I don't think it's going to
make much difference when it's by itself
but I think if if it's on the cloud if
it's if it's the super organism that's
making a I I think that's much more
interesting and I think that's actually
much more likely that a is not going to
come in a standalone machine or
standalone company it'll occur at the
level of the super organism so that's
super intelligence it's not that it's
super like meaning it's better than us I
think it means that it's just going to
operate at a different level because
what we want it's actually we want to
make as many different kinds of minds as
possible and as I will talk about in
just a second I think is really
important that we actually have a
different level of thinking and I think
most of the new startups in the next 100
years are going to follow this formula
take X add AI that's going to be the way
to do it we know about settings search
or internet extraterrestrial
intelligence but David Eagleman and I
are actually trying to do something
called the search or internet
intelligence what would the evidence be
that we would need to see to actually be
convinced that there was kind of a super
intelligence what would what would
convince a skeptic we don't have an
answer but I think it's a good question
we need new governance and this is the
last point I want to make planetary
challenges require planetary thinking
and I use a word challenge because I
mean both problems and the opportunities
of the hollows require whole is thinking
which means we we need to think of the
level of hollows as well as we need to
have a whole those kind of thinking I
mean that's super intelligence but we
cannot just imagine we can't solve
planetary problems without taking the
perspective and and and taking it
seriously the idea that there is this
super organism that we're dealing with I
think we need climate shock and climate
change is going to require
geoengineering he's going to require
planetary scale solutions
Stewart brand was instrumental in giving
us a view of the whole worth and there's
every Astra who's come back if they're
not globalist they're certainly thinking
more globally than they went before
because they understood that this is a
system of three different types Paul
outlet was when the earliest inventors
of hypertext and he devised this idea of
the world encyclopedia the universal
library and not coincidentally he was
instrumental in this idea of the world
city the League of Nations the world
government one world government man if
you want to know about conspiracy and
quacks just delve into this for a second
it used to be on late a.m. it's now
moved to daytime talk radio but any
twelve-year-old anywhere in the world
will tell you that one world government
is inevitable the question is what kind
of world government do we want there are
lots of people trying crazy stuff
they're actually you can get a world
government passport and sometimes border
guards are uninformed enough to let you
through other times or arrest you so
it's a really not a very useful thing to
have but the idea there are many
organizations and the people who are
critics of world government have one
thing right which is there's not an
ounce of democracy in any of those no
one has ever asked the world bank's
never ask me to vote on anything UN has
never asked me to vote but at the same
time they're doing something in the
right direction and I can this is not
really in the same league as these
others I mentioned because it's
something that's trying to cover of the
internet and there's a hope that through
the internet trying to govern that in a
global way we might have learned
something about trying to do it in other
ways but there's a recursive dilemma
which is that who do you who decides
who's going to how this is formed and
who decides who decides
you're gonna have a vote no voting
system is fair they're all fair and
different way unfair in different ways
but who decides what system there is
going to be and who decides who those
people are so there's no way out of that
you basically start unfairly and you try
to work towards fairness but we actually
don't know how to make representative
democracy for seven for nine billion
people we have no idea really how that
would work and there's a bunch of
science fiction authors with Neil
Stevens and others called hieroglyph
which are trying to promote this idea of
working on big problems instead of
little problems Neil I think famously
said the best minds of my generation are
trying to get people to click on ads why
not have them work on a big problem well
here's a big problem how do we have
representative democracy for nine
billion people let's take this idea of a
global superorganism for real there are
lots of challenges I am really concerned
about the fact that we don't have any
rules for cyber war we we we of course
are Americans are very sensitive to the
fact that the Chinese are breaking in
the Americans are breaking into the
Chinese we know that as well but we have
no rules about what's civil what's
honorable what's acceptable nothing at
all we don't know and we don't have a
backup there's if if this goes down even
if it's just a sickness it goes down for
a little while we have nothing
alternative everything's connected
together so this is a very certain we
should at least have a backup that
allows to reboot and we need hollow
thinking we need to have a mind that's
actually bigger than ourselves we need
to have as many different minds as
possible because some of the problems
that we're engaged with cannot be solved
by our minds alone that's one of the
reasons why we want AI is not so much
they're smarter than us is that they
think differently than us so we need to
have different kind of thinking
planetary thinking in order to solve
some of the problems we have
is just the beginning of the beginning I
feel nothing has really happened yet
2014 everything that's happened for us
doesn't really count it's all going to
happen afterwards all the most important
inventions of the next 20-30 years have
not been invented yet so I'm very
optimistic I think that we can take this
idea seriously to try to make a global
holos and try and do our best to make it
benefit us all the species on this
planet and all the robots thank you
[Music]
and that's my book cool tools which I
think there's copies out there it's
self-published and you should get one
for your young friend great have a seat
you said there were seven frontiers you
only showed us five I was a mistake
sorry that was a typo sorry there was a
typo sorry why can't you come up with
two wars several versions of this
question key man according to Alexander
David Campbell says humans evolves in
the context in which social groups were
quite small even today most decisions
are made in a fairly limited scale can
anyone naturally control Technium should
we even try this was some of what you
were getting at the end of you know is
this a democratic thing we're talking
about or what yeah
no there's kind of I think there's a
kind of a Dunbar's number where you have
a natural size of the number of human
relationships that you can deal with I
think that is natural but but I think
that right now we we expect that we will
understand this and I don't think that
we will understand it I don't think we
understand nature we don't know how
nature works but we can still use it so
you can use things that you don't
understand even though you're always
trying to understand more I don't think
that we will necessarily be able to
understand or control it completely so I
think that is that's going to be a big
step that's a big step to acknowledge
the fact that your child will no longer
be under your control and I think you
know there's a famous book by author see
Clark childhoods in I think that's where
we're at is is that we may not have
total control of this thing but doesn't
mean that we aren't going to try to do
the best we can to set it off in the
right direction Darwin noticed that
there was a pattern to how uncontrolled
life was nevertheless pattern and how it
emerged in Geoffrey West spends time
looking not only at cities but at how
the scaling laws apply in natural
systems is that kind of understanding
count yeah I think I think detecting the
super organism we're gonna approach it
maybe like a second nature where we will
go to it in constant all about its
complexity and constantly going to to
learn about it to try and make it useful
to try and bend it to our purposes but
like nature will never successfully be
able to master it I think you know again
Gaia is is beyond our understanding at
some level and certainly beyond our
control anyway we think that event is a
kind of a good thing because this had
four billion years of of learning so
it's very wise I think the Technium does
not have you know it has 200 years maybe
it's not very wise but we can we can
make it we can teach it we can embed
into it some of the principles that we
want in our offspring we we are going to
teach robots ethics and by teaching
robot robot ethics we are going to
become better people because we do
things we drive down the road and we
actually don't even know what we believe
we don't know who we're gonna if we have
to do that paradox of who do you hit we
don't have good answers but when we have
to teach our robots how to drive we're
forced to kind of go through our own
beliefs and our own our own ethics in
order to teach them it's like having
children they often force you to
become better people I'm curious how
with the Technium in mind and trying to
understand the Technium in mind that
explicate the took him in mind how you
find yourself responding to sort of the
the daily course of news so John Markoff
had a piece and page one of the New York
Times today about how you know Osmos
first law of robotics is being routinely
disobeyed by these AI driven missiles
now that are fire-and-forget and are
pretty smart and they will select the
tank rather than another kind of vehicle
and hit it and kill whoever's inside and
in as maz terms caused harm to human
right his items like that come by you
what do you do with that yeah so in this
case I think if we are giving decisions
to these machines and they're making
decisions that we don't like then we
have to teach them better we have to we
have to keep improving them too until
they make decisions that we like it's
not like we just do this once and then
that's the end it's I think it's like oh
that was not that was not a good
decision no we didn't like that okay we
have to do that better and and so it's
again it's like children it's like yeah
you they make a mistake and you kind of
keep reiterating and and you're awesome
forced to think about yourself and I
think that that's the process that we're
gonna have with say AI and these robots
that are being that we're giving some
decision to is that well are these
decisions that we approve do we like
that it collectively as a society if not
let's change that that the algorithm
here's what the sort of conditions of
health of self-healing this kind of
system has
whenever there's something that looks
like it's increasingly accelerating and
going exponential I grew was sort of
came into paying attention and
responsibilities at a time that people
thought that the exponential of
population human population growth was
absolutely catastrophic and could go
nothing but up until everything burrows
where and various ideas were put forward
you know sterile once and the water
supply and things like this that would
somehow get ahead of that and yet the
system turned out to be just another
s-curve that is in fact now leveling off
radically in the nine billion we keep
talking about it's probably the maximum
number of humans on earth that will ever
see we didn't do that that sort of
happened as a byproduct of people moving
to cities for other good reasons that
had nothing to do with worrying about
too many humans yeah are the systems of
this kind of complexity in self
connectedness in some sense self-healing
in that respect yeah there's a good
question I I don't know I mean I do know
that television had probably more effect
on birth rates than anything else and it
had to do with the fact that women could
see role models of women that they
wanted their daughters to grow up to be
and we have a very clear map of that
India where places that TV was
introduced the birth rates fell very
fast so that was not deliberate nobody
was planning to that that was not
conscious is that in some ways a system
effect would we see that on other
planets that's the that's the question
that I asked my cell phone you know if
we went to visit another
khalaqtu another planetary civilization
in the galaxies would they also exhibit
that kind of a pattern i I don't know
where we're stuck because an opinion
about them or their I don't know I don't
have to carry civilizations similar or
yeah that's that's a that's a good
question we we really have no idea and
great thank you but but I do think it's
I mean part of the the reason why Star
Trek and others are interesting is that
they
then let us ask that question is how
much of this stuff is baked into a
system how much is is going to be common
and we don't really know but but we can
at least begin to to to we're certainly
looking for that yeah two questions here
David lang asks what fact or axiom
causes the most problems for your
Technium theory what still doesn't fit
and Kevin Kelly I don't know how he did
this asked what would be evidence that
there is no superorganism so presumably
you do bang yourself with us from time
to time what if this is all completely
wrong yeah and I think as I said in the
beginning I would like to try them they
make this scientific rather than poetic
and the way you do that is you have
something that's falsifiable what could
you say about this that was falsifiable
that we could actually show that did not
exist and I think I don't have very good
reason why it's a good question that
they don't have a very good answer to it
and I and I think the but what I would
like to try and do is is to try and work
towards having something that was
falsifiable a statement about this thing
that we could say well if we discover
this then it proves that this is not
happening
or there's evidence that it was not
happening and I think it might look like
you know when we have X number of things
connected for X number of time that we
that everything was explained I mean
that we never saw any kind of behavior
that we did not expect and so that would
mean trying to write down what kinds of
things we would expect I don't know it's
a very hard thing to it's a very hard
thing because there is a little bit of
that singularity in since it's really
hard for us to see beyond into that
level of organization so how you prove a
negative is is tough well some of you
can break down the mechanism so Gaia
theory is challenged basically on the
mechanisms level of you know are there
really these self-enhancing and
self-limiting mechanisms
JimBob Locke imagine as hydrogen sulfide
you know make clouds in the ocean
because of warming and things like this
and some of those have held up and some
of not likewise the singularity is
pretty much based on an idea of a set of
connected things all accelerating right
a certain rate and if they don't all
keep accelerating at the rate the Ray is
carts then you would say well that
particular version of thing about the
singularity isn't right because the
numbers don't hold up right are there
places like that and your Technium
theory that you could say that
aha see it's really happening or mmm
yeah it's not another way say that is
can we make some predictions about
something that might happen good so I
might make a prediction that there'll be
a 1 million person flash crowd that
happens in the next 10 years you know
but is that enough to convince anybody I
don't know the physical walkers yeah
physically whether it's gonna be like a
Woodstock where 1 million people will
show up somewhere and everybody will be
amazed but it'll seem like oh uh
afterwards they'll see my goal obviously
yes of course
so so I you know I think I think that
would be one good way would be to make
some predictions about behavior that we
might expect to see I don't have those
but I think I would like to work towards
that
Tyler Willis asks this technology ever
evolve far enough to limit or negate
humanity's role in holes yeah do we fall
out of the equation I think that's a
very common fear these days because we
see mmm things happening fast it's
sometimes there's a sense that the speed
is happening so fast that the that that
speed leaves us behind sometimes it's a
scale and the the reason I guess I'm not
as worried as many people are about it
is because I've served seen what we've
done with other species I think there
was a period of time where we did maybe
care about whether other species
survived or not but then we recognized
that in every species is so
of a wealth a bank of learning
it's whatever species you can find on
earth has gone through the equal number
of amount of evolution as almost four
billion years of evolution in this thing
and and and that that information that
that knowledge is actually can be useful
to us and we need it and our lives are
also improved or bettered by having
multiple species around us so we're no
longer interested in sort of getting rid
of species we're actually interested in
reviving species and I think where do
they fit in the Technium Gabriel I think
it's a question on that I think what
happens is that as I'm saying is that we
want to have as many different kinds of
thinking as many different kinds of
devices that we possibly can because it
because there's going to be problems
that we encounter what we need to have
other beings or other kinds of thinking
that the r-type it's the only reason to
make an AI is not to make one like
humans but to make one different than
humans and so that that is where this
power comes from we we need collectively
to have other kinds of thinking other
kinds of beings other kinds of existence
in order to solve the problems that we
have made so there's you know one of the
kind of romantic argument against
letting languages go exchanges when the
language goes extinct the world it
disappears and it's not entirely
romantic often what's a native language
they have a whole bunch of knowledge
about the other organisms in their
system and what they're good for and how
they refer to them and where they fit
into their stories and so on and it
sounds like you're saying that letting
other organisms go you also lose a world
in each time and thereby impoverished
the one that we share and I would say
and by inventing other kinds of beings
we actually are creating those new
worlds we're creating more of our world
that that that we it's it's by
surrounding ourselves with as many
different I'll call them being as many
different kinds of thinking many
different perspectives many different
creatures we actually
a better our world a better ourselves
because right now we're on a
century-long identity crisis we don't
know what humans are good for we don't
know why we're here we don't know why
we're different than anything else and
so we need all these things to help us
answer that question about what is a
human and what's a human form well this
is sort of been Danny Hillis historian
as part of the founding of the long now
foundation as he had the feeling that of
what had been humanity's story for a
while which was essentially control of
nature is his story which is with the
arrival of the Anthropocene and complete
or at least the completion is in sight
and that we're now in this entangled
process of trying to figure out what the
next story is all right do you think the
next story is in some sense the Technium
yeah I think the next story is going to
be this another level of our existence
and again I think maybe leaving behind
the last remnants of our tribal nature
which is nationalism I mean nationalism
is a terrible disease that needs to be
that we need to cure ourselves of and I
think that that next story would be a
more of a planetary story and it's going
to be more of an all species story and
it's gonna be one of you know multiple
Minds story where we have we are making
Minds that will have certain dimensions
that are better than us in thinking and
together all these different kinds of
minds thinking we can solve problems
that we can't solve right now I mean
maybe that parts of physics are simply
going to be unsolvable by human minds
alone we and we may need to make these
other kind of minds to help us even
understand quantum gravity a question we
avoided revived restores it ok to bring
me and ourselves back this sounds like
you wouldn't mind a bit no I would love
to have Neanderthals
who won't I mean it's like hey save one
why I think what if one of this one of
the sources of our arrogance is the fact
that we don't have any other competing
intelligences we've basically probably
murdered most of them and that by having
by having something else that's similar
to us it will force us to be better in a
sense of being more distinguished about
what we're doing being more careful
about how we do it and having this is
like having competition and since me we
have someone else to reflect back to us
and we can see ourselves a little better
by having something else similar to us
and I said I think the Neanderthal would
be tremendous gift for us to realize
more about who we are
well speaking space yours comes question
from Australia
Nick Hodges asks given we've just landed
on a comment what do you impact do you
think the Technium will have on the
solar system and oh what the hell galaxy
yeah I'm sure that will you know diffuse
into space we've already begun with
comets and we'll have one-way missions
to Mars as a reality TV program I'm sure
where you buy into one one-way missions
well yeah that's that's the current plan
right now is there's a one-way mission a
one-way mission to Mars and it's a
reality it's financed by being a rowdy
TV program the entire world will watch
to see with how long they live and
there's no end of people who would
volunteer for it and we've learned a lot
Anson's you know lower space tourists
vehicle crashed and killed somebody the
other day yeah I see that as not slowing
anything no absolutely not makes it more
interesting yeah there will still be
people who go and I know and I think
that that that's pretty inevitable that
we even know I think it's really a bad
idea to send
into space I think we will you know it's
it's so it sounds like net case yours
fan of downloading us into non-meat
things yeah I think with virtual reality
and those kinds of things that we could
the lag time is horrible yeah it is yeah
move over yeah it's it's it's terrible
but I think with a eyes and stuff like
that we can we can do a lot of it III
don't think that it will prevent us from
actually having people who want to risk
their life to go out there and we'll do
everything they can but I think it's I
think most of the exploration will be
not done by by bodies so it'll be done
by our extended bodies and there will
still be some you know the equivalent of
the Amish in space you know who want to
be there in their bodies Danny Hillis he
was talking with Brian Eno earlier this
year said that if he was a grad student
now he would not be studying computer
science would be studying synthetic
biology this was in context of Brian
saying that Mars is really boring why
would anybody go there and Danny
basically saying you know you know we
can make versions of humans biologically
that would be meat a version of meat
that's welcome to space and would very
much enjoy the right nature of the low
sunlight and low gravity and right
exactly as long as Danny that is to make
people really really small mm-hmm make
humans this big because they do better
in space rusty Schweickart comment is
the first thing you discover in space is
there's no use for legs whatsoever
hey just getting away all the good for
yeah and you know we probably know the
genes that make legs and so we can do
yeah that pretty quick well I think or
determine does I think one of the
central questions in the long term in
the very very long term is going to be
whether we remain one species are many
ah
and whether we remained of one mind or
many and I think the Technium is always
gonna be one it sounds like yes but I
think we will specie 8 and I think
there'll be Naturals and people who will
say under no circumstances will I or any
of my descendants ever have our genes
touched and then there'll be other
people who will say like you know
tomorrow yeah something up you do
anything you want or transform myself
and and I think that that will lead to a
natural
forking in in us and so I think we will
have the other sense of pace of that is
that this century no no not this century
no no your biology is so difficult to
move my wife was here too I mean she
works with living things and it's so so
hard to to change things because it's
four billion years of accumulated trial
and error and working and it's so hard
to move that that I don't I think that's
a very slow process I'm not saying it's
impossible I think it's really slow yeah
well encode terms is the classic ball of
mud yeah and trying to reverse engineer
what was never engineered I mean I think
we will do a piecemeal but I think it's
a long-term project so is it the case
that you know those holes another big
ball of mud that it's in a sense not
programmable yeah I think there are
gonna be aspects of it that are not
programmable by us but the point is is
there's a lot probably a lot that is and
it's like it's like well government okay
world government is inevitable but the
question is what kind of well there's
still lots of choices to make and I
think the whole list is the same thing
there's there's there's huge amount this
is beyond anything that we could do and
program but there's still so much that
we can do that we can focus on on the
parts that we have some
influence and power over to what you can
hope for the best
Don means ass what does hold us what
what does hollows what I think it wants
what many systems want and and that is
one is it wants to survive and prosper
and two alters environment to be more
conducive to more of itself so it will
it will take all the money and energy
that it can possibly get and brain power
to try and make it more complex or
energy efficient or diverse more mutual
I mean it'll do the same thing the
evolution it's done it's basically in
this extension of evolution forces the
self-organization it's going to do what
also organized entities have done which
is to bend whatever it can to make it
more conducive so they can deepen so I
think what it wants the Hollis wants to
be more follow hollows it wants to be
more of itself and I think that's sort
of what all we're all working on it
as holos close the way you describe it
is it's kind of engineering what sense
is it science it's not science right now
it's still on the verge of on the edge
of poetry but at what but it needs to be
taken scientifically it needs we need to
treat it in you know describe it is my
first attempt we should trying to
describe this we should test it
in the sense of make predictions try to
understand it as much as we can to what
what experiments come to mind to you you
get a sense of some of the currently
unknown but it would be nice to know
yeah what we don't know is so vast but I
mean I think even you know having kind
of global logs of
of the traffic a global measuring its
rhythms in energy use metabolism treat
you know looking at this metabolism as a
whole so in the first sense I think the
first step is observation collecting
data about the thing and then we can
begin to try and do some experiments
make some predictions and collect more
data so so right now what I'm suggesting
I think we're at the stage of let's just
observe and collect as much data as we
can about it
and then if people treat it seriously
this makes some hypothesis some
predictions and then what then I think
like anything I think that if we even if
we even just had a sense that it was
real then we could begin to pay
attention to it and I think we could in
the areas that were possible we could
train it you know we could bring in the
things that we want it to be we could
guide it in terms of the places that
it's growing if we if it has to have
ethical if we wanted to be friendly then
we want to bring all these things into
it then we want to engage with it
so so I'm a big believer that the way we
the way you deal with technology is that
you engage with it and you engage with
them by using it so we want to use this
and to use it we have to understand that
it's there so so what we don't want to
do is is to prohibit it or prevent it or
pretend that it's not there
we engage with it and say okay this is
it what can we do let's observe it and
then interact with it is very comfort be
is it because sense is it be comforted
by the hive
it's a it's hollows comforting that's
interesting question you're not
terrified by it any other no I'm not
terrified by it I haven't thought about
being comforted by it I think I think
it's it's a it's a fair question would
people ever sing a song for it would
would we ever write an ode to it I I
believe we might and and actually I
think that the Technium
as it continues to complexify even to
stages were really as beyond our
understanding that we might even come to
it like Cathedral and feel an awe in it
or like a woods or redwoods in in the
sense of that that we would really find
it inspiring in some message so so I
think eventually yes we could come to it
maybe we would even feel proud about it
oh yeah my holos it's it's that holos is
this really yeah it's possible I mean
III you know I think that would be
better than talking about your nation
and I think you know it's could we be
proud of it well that's maybe a good
thing to aim for I'd like to make a
whole list that we would be proud of and
it would probably be proud to have you
do that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]